i'm so curious because uh you started
filming this back in 1982.
so that sounds right it's true
ladies and gentlemen how are you guys
doing so good excellent i'm so curious
because you did film and then you were
shut down because of covid while you
were shut down did things get tweaked in
the editing room what did you learn when
you were cutting what you shot that sort
of impacted the finished
you know the episodes it actually gave
us i mean kova was terrible we all
acknowledged that but that time off
gave us time to do a lot of this
recalibration he was talking about gave
me time to breathe with the scripts and
actually work on the back half of the
season and also gave our visual effects
team
time to catch up with all the work that
was needed to be done so we were still
working the entire time just remotely on
editorial visual effects and on scripts
and so
and also just as you said like learning
different things about um just technical
small stuff like how do the armor fit
well or what what
what set looks good in a certain
direction so it just gave us time to to
take what we learned from the previous
six months of filming five months of
filming and then do better when we got
back and i think that
um as challenging it was to come as it
was to come back during covet you know
with all the protocols and the bubbles
and the groups and the masks and the you
know filming under those circumstances
wasn't easy at all but we had more
wisdom and have had had time those six
months to sort of learn that i think
made the show better television
production can oftentimes be like this
speeding train you know that gets going
and you just you can't stop because
everybody wants to continue to to make
sure it gets done right and so when
covet happened it
made us stop that train exactly where we
were look at everything we had done and
reassess and figure out what the best
path forward was and it i think was one
of the best things that happened to us
production-wise because it forced us to
look at where we were decide where we
wanted to go and really just gave
everybody a chance to catch up you know
as steve said visual effects and all
that stuff
everything is just in a place where
you're like yeah just getting a step
behind and to be able to say okay wait a
second you know or have to do that uh
really really saved us on many levels
and as much as i'm sorry oh it got us
out of the weeds creatively too right
because when you're on that train you're
just you have that tunnel vision and it
let us sort of raise our horizon line
and kind of look across what we've done
and what we had left to go and sort of
how best to focus and what was or wasn't
working particularly
sort of shift as we came back so having
that
being able to be a little bit more
objective about it for a while um i
think helped us yeah i came on board the
train was already going so i was put i
was building track as the train was
moving so it helped me but uh i think
also coming back
during covet ironically considering how
we had to be so separate from each other
during covet you know no no one was in
the same band anymore no one was
socializing
uh going through that together i think
brought the crew and the cast together
in a different way and i think the um
the effort that the crew especially the
thousand people working on the show did
during covet
i think also contributed to just making
the show what it is successful because i
think everyone felt
that we were a family building this
thing together and it comes through did
you guys do any like additional
photography for the first episodes that
you had shot when you got back well we
owed a lot of stuff anyway so we were
always shooting out of order but
certainly we had time to cut episodes
and say you know what we could actually
use an extra connective tissue here or
let's reshoot that scene
very few of those thankfully um to make
it work better now that we know where
it's going that kind of stuff so any any
chance you could
have to redo anything we took during
covid but also we had so much to do when
we got back so it was really more about
fine tuning
and preparing for the next
for for shooting again and doing things
better this is based on a super popular
video game and with die hard fans what
were some of the like the third rail
things that you're like we cannot change
this under any circumstances it was
tough and i think it was there's sort of
two things one is
optimizing for the medium and optimizing
for telling this character story and
there's also
wanting to give that halo audience a
different experience from the games not
just to say here you can play your game
and here you can watch your game in live
action so the intent really was for it
to
bring you into the universe and let you
experience it in a different way i think
the things that were were sacred
um were
the themes of halo the things that that
sort of resound through any halo
experience which is those themes of hope
and heroism and humanity and sort of the
wonder and mystery of sci-fi
those were sacred and then we would look
at in the same way
you know the spirit of a character right
not not just the the sort of um
on paper attributes but who do they mean
to people and who are what is the
character of the character
um and same with with moments like
what's sort of the intent of a moment
what's sort of the meta of a moment not
just the snapshot you may have
experienced in the games and so that's
how we approached that and then there's
you know the the the sounds and the
sights and all of those what is the
foundation of those from silhouette and
function and the things that sort of
define them but how do you bring them
into live action how do you bring them
into a real world and make them feel
grounded and credible
you know even even with you know with
cortana how do you bring a hologram
into live action and have her act
alongside real people
um and have that feel like it's
believable and have that be a character
that that the actors and other
characters can connect with so cortana
is who she is like that spirit of her
she looks a little bit different in the
games and frankly she looks different in
every game that we release
all all on how do we make it feel like
everyone is and everything is of the
universe so people should feel like
they're stepping into a halo world right
and a halo story
but we definitely have taken liberties
and and established the silver timeline
so the story could grow the way it
needed to without burdening the game and
vice versa what's great too is you would
allow us to
dig into the halo verse and i might say
hey there's this character that shows up
once in a graphic novel or in a comic in
a book or in a game but we don't have
much besides their character title and
their rank can we give them a life and
we would work together to actually build
out that which is the most fun part
right yeah you know the rubble you never
actually see you read about it and
building that space out was incredibly
gratifying creatively of the nine
episodes is there one specifically that
you would recommend fans look
a little deeper to find an easter egg or
two
episode
[Laughter]
we have little ones sort of spread
throughout
some quite obscure for very very deep
lore fans i'm in seven
for sure
i wasn't on easter egg duty but yeah
i'm particularly partial to episode six
i i really enjoy the arc of episode six
and and how it feels as a kind of
standalone thing so i'm looking oh do
share more please i'm looking i'm
looking forward to people experiencing
that one that's the spoiler i can give
six watch it but you know what i have to
say we have this
brilliant um is she an art director ava
what is what do we call her
graphics person but everyone's brilliant
but we have certain people who who would
design things working with kiki and 343
on canon and just put stuff into scenes
so it could be a billboard on a building
in the distance with an advertisement
for if you're a halo fan you'll
recognize the product that they're
selling or just little things like that
that just sort of halsey's lab
yeah
is
ripe
easter eggs yeah and then even in terms
of phrase sometimes we'll try to find
something from the show from the game or
a reference to something that we don't
actually go forward but it's if you have
your antenna up and you're a halo person
you'll you'll get it another thing i'm
very curious about um who borrowed what
from set with every intention of
bringing it back when you start building
season two
any thiefs in the back row what would
you say he said my mullet
you're in the mullet
you gave that back right away yeah yeah
yeah
smaller didn't come home
i think it's like harder on a on a
show like this to
like i think on other jobs i've been
like oh i've accidentally gone home with
my earrings but on this like i'm not
gonna accidentally go home and like some
you know halo sci-fi trousers you know
i'm gonna remember that i'm wearing
those you know so i i have something oh
i'm not gonna tell you
i know the lady spartans were very very
eager to try to get home with their
helmet
i'm pretty sure neither one managed
that's right um yeah
i think there's a lot of people making
sure they never do
do i even want to know or defend how and
maybe you don't have an answer you want
to share it but how expensive is it to
make that helmet and to make those the
the suits
well when you see them littered across
the battle it's a lot it gets more and
more expensive
in the uk yeah
yeah they were built at uh fbfx in the
uk who are who are outstanding yeah
they're um
you know they're
highly expensive plastic and um
what we found is they just don't hold up
the way virtual armor does so crazy yeah
literally like it looks like a crash
site every time there's a battle scene
um we had an amazing team on set who are
helping literally like taping gluing
sewing i think a lot of people don't
realize that sometimes the people that
cosplay and make their own costumes can
be actually better than what's being
used on set yeah because they're
building they're the ones wearing it and
building it
right so they're highly aware i'm sure
shout out to cosplay
yeah they're good costumes i'm not sure
they're better than fbfx versions uh
they they are these things look pretty
darn good
amazing they have held up you know they
it's hard to try to put them through the
rigors of battle they're not real armor
you know it's not mjolnir it's just
plastic and i i have so much respect for
the people who built it because it does
look so amazing and and it is functional
to a certain point but there's only so
much you can do when you're like rolling
around and blowing [ __ ] up and you know
my poor balance
is my one of my favorite guys on set
he was our costume repair guy and he was
definitely the busiest man on set he was
overseeing all of the spartans every
time they were there running around
picking up our spare pieces and splash
gluing them on
but these guys and gals in the armor
looked incredible the funny noises that
you would make too the plant like just
walking around you could hear them
coming squeezing i actually was curious
how many takes were ruined because
someone was laughing from a weird sound
of the armor well i don't know about the
laughing part but i will tell you that i
am now in the process of doing adr for
uh the season one of halo and i don't
believe there's a single line
that is production you know audio it's
all being reported i call them the
clydesdales you could literally hear
them from behind coming the best was
these giant chairs on set you know the
little director's chairs they have these
guys big camping chairs like canopies
they would just sit in them like they're
like they see oh you need to share this
online yeah
we have lots of pictures don't worry
uh for this version of halo was it ever
almost like a completely different show
like how did you decide this is the
exact story we want to tell especially
in the first season yeah well a lot of
that came before me um when i came on
board
the prior writing team kyle kellen had
already kind of
chosen a path and carved out an idea
and so i came in and sort of built on
that um but you can speak to before i
got there there was yeah i mean i would
say part of the the length of process
was
trying to figure out the right story to
tell and so we did go through a few a
few different iterations we went through
a few iterations where
um it was very much a retelling
of stories we've told before we went
iterations that was way out there and i
think we ended up in a place that you
know really takes a lot of what exists
already in halo but also builds a lot of
great news story on top of it and so
yeah there was there was quite a bit of
exploration
and that was just organic right because
there's not a formula we just had to
sort of feel our way through it i think
the path was actually really
uh that's the smart one which is you
know you're you're telling the story of
master chief who in the game you you are
master chief right so
he is sort of a mystery and there's
canon about his backstory but the idea
of who he really is is a bit of a
mystery so i think was really smart of
the prior writers and then built on is
to sort of take the first season and say
well who is master chief let's do it
through master chief himself discovering
his own who he is and then that built
onto a theme of as he discovers his own
humanity we start asking questions about
humanity and that just laid out sort of
a a theme for every other character and
for the whole season this idea of
whether it's ai and
this cortana can she ever be human
whether it's
how much of your own humanity you want
to sacrifice to save humanity it all
starts stemmed from master chief's
personal journey of discovery did you
sort of map out in an ideal world we are
going to do five seasons and we are
going to hit each mark on each season
like how did you figure out where do we
want the the story to to sort of um stop
at the end of season one you know what i
mean yeah yeah i think you know this one
was interesting because um
i think that's that's sort of the ideal
approach of you know what do we want the
next five ten years to look like like
that's how we we approach the the games
as well but i think also once we got
into the story and really the focus of
it being
chief finding his humanity
right or understanding what his humanity
means
um understanding who john is i think as
we got into that
um we focused really on on what that
that arc could be because it was so hard
to figure out the right balance with
with canon
and news story and so i think we're
we're now at a point where
we're looking ahead to the next five
years and so
um we definitely were a little more
organic season one
but i think we now have sort of that
sense of path and we have so many places
we can go right that becomes the hardest
part which is if we're focusing on the
character
what of all those stories in those
places is the right way to tell that
story versus we want to make sure to hit
just this thing or that thing and a lot
of us meant having restraint because i
would get enthusiastic why don't we show
this why don't we and then we'll come
conversations and say you know what
let's hold that for there's more to come
you know so it was about
what not to include as opposed to what
to include because you could you could
go crazy trying to get everything in
there at once and it's kind of nice to
sort of
sort of wait and have patience and let
it play and keep the focus on
the characters speaking of chief and the
characters uh the first episode you are
introduced to a planet to these new
characters and all of a sudden the
covenant and this is all before you even
see the title halo so i'm just curious
what was it actually like filming that
action set piece because that is not
something that gets filmed in an
afternoon
that is a certainly wasn't right exactly
this one was a hero through that whole
process yeah honestly yes i threw the
whole show she's she's a trooper man
what was it like shooting that sequence
so much running so much funny
i mean she's just very lucky but she
yeah it was just like a whole month of
just running away from explosives
literally trying to not die
but it was a lot of fun and um there's a
lot of um people who support you and
make you feel safe and um yeah the stunt
team were great and
i think the sequences were really um
well planned out and i think that always
helps
um yeah it's a lot of fun
we we shot that sequence at the end
in the spring because we needed good
weather
which apparently
hungarian springs are very unpredictable
so we literally had snow sleet rain
freezing temperature
over 100 degree temperature all
in that one sequence
yeah we had uh
we put actually all the action sequences
were at the end of the show i think it
mostly happened that way because of
covid restrictions
originally it was going to be sort of
uh sort of that way with the action
stuff interspersed at the end with some
of the the more dramatic stuff and then
because covid uh and the weather it just
we had uh
episode one
five and nine which contain you know
most of the larger the vfx team was very
happy about
all that stuff
at the end of the shoot right it's so
crazy because everyone i speak to who
makes other things movies and other
series they all say we shoot the big vfx
first so the vfx team has the most time
right working on these shots yeah we
were behind schedule from day one yeah
and vfx wise because
well leaving in march right we were
supposed to start shooting in the spring
and when covet hit and we all left in
march of of 2020 that that really
disrupted the schedule yeah so that
actual sequence which is
i'm going to say six or seven minutes of
screen time how long did that actually
take you to film that was uh otto
bathurst was the director of the first
two episodes so he had already been
there to shoot most of the first two
episodes earlier on and then he came
back for i believe eight or nine days
ten days of shooting so it was around
two weeks or three weeks including yeah
it was three weeks he heavily
storyboarded like
all all credit to auto for there was no
way we could have gotten through that
much with all of the weather changes and
all that without sort of meticulous
planning and storyboarding and the
location was amazing sophie basher
beecher sophie beecher who was our art
art director for the first season did
amazing work um created this just
wonderful uh set inside what was it an
old aluminum factory or something like
that so it was this contained circle
that had our whole set and everything
else outside on the show is visual
effects but
inside that circle of the aluminum
factory with this weird um sky pipe that
ended up being our sky uh was all
contained set and and really really
amazing beautiful and that's sad outside
for a year right because of the delay
which actually weathered it in this
perfect perfect way
also you have to plan every shot because
a lot of shots had aliens in them so you
can't just say well we'll just point the
camera this direction it was okay now
you have to figure out the visual
effects of that as well and incorporate
that into your planning so it was
meticulously done in spite all the crazy
weather you guys went through and the
heavy armor you had to wear and running
around and jumping and
it was yeah and it showed up on google
maps i tried to get it taken down
yeah they were like
yaren you spend a lot of that episode
with blood on your face
and i'm just curious what is that like
because that can't be pleasant to have
that stuff all over you all the time no
it's a lot of um time in the makeup
chair in the morning and continuity is
yeah very particular um but to be honest
with you i kind of just forget about it
and then when people look at me in the
morning they're like oh you're in and
i'm like oh i forget that i have blood
all over my face did you ever want to
leave set and just like go to a local
supermarket and just walk through with
that blood because i think
it would just be a blast to see people's
reactions just i think it would be fun
yeah i'm sad i didn't do that but we
were in the middle of nowhere
yeah i would i would have if we were in
the city but next season yeah next year
more blood more blood
yeah
the first two episodes obviously when
you're filming you are imagining so many
different things what was it actually
like seeing everything for the first
time
i'll start because i i can fill in some
of that because i've been watching it as
as it's gone along and one of the most
amazing things of this whole process has
been seeing the visual effects get
filled in you know because you start
with this
uh like you said acting in front of a
green screen or acting in that circle a
set that was created with nothing behind
it and then every single cut that comes
in gets progressively more detailed and
the vfx team's doing an amazing job on
it and so watching it come together in
that way is one of the great joys of
watching the process i was obviously not
experiencing all the um
adversity that yaren and other
characters were but it was just in my
lab but we were acting or i was acting
with just a green screen as you say
nothing sort of trying to imagine what
might be put on the monitors so then to
actually
see the first two episodes and see all
the fill-in and the kind of realization
of
holsi's creations up there and the
process that she goes through in order
to create cortana was incredibly cool
yeah very gratifying the first two
episodes really opened the door to this
universe and all these characters and
all the places you could go um for fans
that are so excited what can you tease
about like the rest of the season i'm
just excited for people to see the show
unfold because it as you've commented it
begins with a bang it begins it really
sets the stage for what you can expect
from the rest of the season
but it's also it delivers in my opinion
on different levels it's not just for
action fans or sci-fi fans or even halo
fans although they will hopefully all be
well rewarded for their time it's it's
just a really fun amazing story of a
journey of a character and the other
characters discovering themselves and
this existential war for their own
survival against the aliens it's it's a
sort of an epic opera
um
it's set in 26th century but really
grounded in just
everyday emotions and so i think it's
it's going to be a feast for the eyes
but also hopefully really just a
compelling story and every episode lays
out a little bit more and so you get
more and more invested with master
chief's journey
and more invested in this universe and i
think hopefully by the end you're as
you could come to it having never played
the game once and you're now
on footing with everyone else in the
halo verse who
you know loves this cannon because
you're we're just bringing you in a
different direction i think also like
all good sci-fi it asks the sort of deep
existential questions about why we're
here how we got here what we value what
we don't value what's
fashion and as of now even if it's a
kind of you know moral fashion and you
re you look at a different moral
construct and
if you're looking from that point of
view was what happened to master chief
morally reprehensible or in fact if
you're saving the future of mankind does
anything go you know long-term gain for
short-term pain sort of all of those
questions we spoke about
in depth um as well as a.i and
singularity what what or
i think from halsey's point of view
there's a sort of strange
schism that happens which she feels
entirely in control of her creation and
is quite confident that this is going to
work
and then
there's a certain point
at which
cortana develops empathy let's say well
maybe
we we haven't explored that fully
but
that sort of idea of
i suppose the scientist
she has a huge ego but her curiosity is
even greater than her ego so watching
master chief's behavior and watching him
change
um and perhaps be less respectful less
responsive start to ask more questions
she's more excited by that in a way
than even
being disobeyed or disrespected or sort
of losing control i've found that really
fun to play with halsey your character
seems like she will go to any length to
accomplish her mission do you think
there's a line that she will not cross
to make whatever she thinks is necessary
happen be careful she's really good at
justifying really reprehensible
but but actually to that point what i
found really exciting about this project
and why i wanted to do it
you know many reasons i wanted to do it
but one of the big reasons i wanted to
do it was to ask those questions
that i feel we should be asking every
day anyway which is what what is
um i suppose a response to
groupthink and what is actually progress
and
can you do things that feel morally
reprehensible
to the current status quo
but actually i mean let's look i know
galileo or someone you know he said
something that at the time he was put in
jail for and yet we now all know to be
true i was working on that sort of
premise that what happens if future if
you're protecting future generations and
if actually you care more about the
future than you do about the present
does that make you a terrible person i
think all of those things are
fascinating and i can go on forever
i told you
villain never sees himself as a villain
the big thing for for us the word i kept
using whether it was with actors with
writing with the composers is this idea
of yearning
every character is yearning for
something just out of their reach and
for halsey it's this idea that there's
an intelligence in the universe that she
wants to get to know
and that leads to a lot of her
machiavellian sort of approach but it's
also based on a real sincere human
hope to aspire to greater things to
reach for that and so every character in
their own ways on that journey including
the at the aliens who are trying to
reach for something beyond their grasp
and they have an idea of what they think
it is uh the covenant and uh so it sort
of
puts a of sort of a veneer of nobility
to everybody's quests and sometimes
their methods might be
not so noble but we can at least relate
to their to their yearning uh jen when
you booked halo way back when uh you had
no idea what this game was going to
become and no idea just how popular this
thing would be
when you were asked to be a part of the
series
at first were you like is someone
punking me right now like
i got an email from my darling friend
kiki here and yes i
i think i've read the emails several
times and i think
my husband was in the middle of work and
i knocked on his office door and said i
need you to end your meeting i need you
to answer me
[Music]
funked is a great way to
it's a great way to describe it what can
you tease about cortana's role over the
course of the season this character gets
to have some moments in this show some
experiences in the show that i have
never experienced in
the 20 years of playing this role how's
that
i think that's the good teaser i get
some fun interesting things that i've
never done i think one of the
interesting things about the chief
cortana dynamic that uh that is
different from the games or that that is
exciting for people who who love the
games is that you get to see their
relationship at a different point than
you ever do in the games
it's early on in the chief cortana
relationship and that dynamic you get to
see kind of how how their relationship
began which is an interesting place to
take it from andrew you get to see much
more of dr halsey and cortana in their
relationship which is something that we
don't do a lot of in the games um you
sort of see the creation of her but you
also see there's always been such an
interesting sort of
triangulation with chief and halsey and
cortana that we see in the games and
this really explores the relationships
individually which i think
adds an added dimension to the dynamic
and i think the story also sort of
pushes on on the boundaries of those
relationships in a in a super
interesting and different way and
there's a great bond that forms between
chief and cortana in the sense that
they're both halsey's children in some
way
uh and of course there's also um
miranda who is halsey's child so there's
that sort of weird dynamic that
um all these characters have to do we're
sisters
yeah i mean and we explore that to a
certain degree coming up you know in
later episodes the idea of the
relationship between miranda and the
other spartans um because they are in
some ways
siblings and
so um i don't know if you wanna
yeah i mean it's it's very interesting
that dynamic definitely because i think
that halsey
uh albeit potentially unethically but
more attentively
definitely has raised
um the spartans and even cortana in in
in a way than uh miranda so
that was something super interesting to
play with
she's just upscaling her motherhood
outsourcing
abandoning her own
um i think this might be my last
question for you guys uh for each of you
which scene or sequence are you most
excited for people to see and in what
episode well i for me it's it's sort of
twofold i think the
the
scenes in five and nine that are
powerful game-changing scenes are going
to be unforgettable for the audience uh
just in terms of the kinetic visceral
experience of it all
i think that there are as popular saying
there's
small emotional scenes like in six and
seven
and an eight
especially uh and then and nine finale
um it's those little moments i think
that actually i live for you know um so
you're gonna get
i'm excited for people just to get the
experience of sitting back and being
overtaken by the power of the images of
certain certain scenes coming up but i
think it's the smaller intimate ones
that are gonna get you coming back
so i'm excited for people to see that
for me i think episode one uh obviously
which you've already seen uh i'm very
eager obviously for audiences worldwide
to to experience
the helmet removal so we can get that
out of the way and
you know begin begin the process of the
discovery of the
chiefs humanity and john humanity and
which is really like you know the course
of our season but i'm also very excited
for fans to get to experience episode
five i think it's going to be a real
pleaser for for the fandom um so those
are my my highlights
uh i think one of my favorite moments is
in episode three as we've already
spoiled when when cortana appears sort
of the birth of cortana
because it's such an amazing moment to
watch dr halsey
see this um see cortana come to life i
think it's like it's sort of a unique
moment for halsey in the show and a
place where to me it feels like you see
her so genuinely
um
so that was a favorite of mine for me a
lot of the stuff i really love is the
humor
that is unexpected there's quite a lot
between
um
[Music]
yaron and and pablo i shouldn't say yeah
and in public i should i should i should
say your character's names but but
anyway that there's some stuff amidst
the mayhem that just some questions that
she asks in in
you know in a very guileless way which i
which i really loved i thought that was
very cool and um
there's a moment of another character i
can't say because it's later on but
there's just a few delicious moments
where
humor just cuts through um the drama
which i think
again good sci-fi you get that bad
sci-fi there's no humor um and it's all
very honest and
yeah leaves me cold whereas this i feel
it gets elevated all the time but and
the spartans too the interplay between
them i really love yeah
i spend a lot of time experiencing um
the world through what pablo is
experiencing you know through what the
chief is experiencing and there is one
scene in particular that i'm really
curious
how it came out um
and i'm excited um and i'm excited and
it was an interesting experience for me
to film so i'm really eager to see that
you don't want to hint if it's in the
back half of the season what episode is
it in you guys know what i believe
you're talking about eight eight oh
eight oh i know exactly yeah yeah that's
true that's very good yes for you guys i
think um
episode four
for me i'm super excited to see
um
some
developments and discoveries
and also
um
a big pivot for kwan's
character storyline on that note i need
to rap and just say thank you so much
for talking um and thank you for making
a caca show
you